this construction site behind me has
become a debris field after an explosion
shook this East End Ottawa neighborhood
a doorbell camera captured the moment a
ball of flames shot into the sky a gas
leak set off the blast around 6 a.m
leveling four homes under construction
two people were trapped under the
wreckage one was stuck for three hours
emergency crews used chainsaws to cut
through the debris and pull them to
safety
the two were sent to hospital in serious
but stable condition the damage in the
area is widespread the blast shook homes
across the street we spoke to some of
the neighbors who woke up to the bang it
was 6 a.m I was in a deep sleep and all
I hear is Boom felt like a truck just
ran into the house I wake up go check on
my little girl she's only four months
old she's still asleep though I thought
someone crashed into our house so I
immediately ran upstairs to check out my
other child when I looked outside I just
saw debris everywhere in the air the
Salvation Army and Red Cross are here
helping people displaced by the
explosion this has now moved into an
investigation phase which includes
Ontario's Ministry of Labor
tariya isri Global News Ottawa